what's up everybody
my goodness end almost the end of day
three of what an amazing conference so
far it's so good to be hanging out with
you all and thank you so much for
hanging around uh and coming to see this
talk
um my name is Van Ash I'm a developer
Advocate at a company called sonar
uh sonar if you don't know uh provide
static analysis tools that you can use
in your applications to help build uh
help you build clean maintainable code
bases
um uh we have been hanging around at the
conference with a little booth obviously
there's not much time but if you do want
to find out more come down find us
before the end we'll be hanging out
until the very death
get this I think we might have given all
the glasses gloss away now
otherwise my name is onash uh you can
find me all over the internet as
Phil Nash I guess
um in as many places as I could get that
handle you can find me there
um I love connecting with people and if
you ever have any questions obviously
feel free to reach out on any of these
platforms
today I want to talk about passwords or
the title of the talk is the state of
passwordless uh off on the internet uh
but
um
we can't talk about passwordless without
at least considering passwords in the
first place because they're terrible
I hope you are sort of in agreement
that's why you might show up uh to a
talk about getting rid of them uh
because you are hopefully out of the
agreement that they are terrible but I
have some reasons just in case you need
convincing
uh first up
um Google did a survey back in December
of 2018 in which they asked a bunch of
questions about people's account
security and they asked one including
you know how often do you reuse
passwords
um and so this blue section here on the
on the right says 52 of people said they
reuse passwords some of the time
well done
um I guess that's some sort of an amount
of honesty I guess reusing passwords
some of the time is the sort of
imperfect way of dealing with it I like
the people in the green section 35 of
people said they never reuse passwords
and I hope that we all number amongst
them
but I'm really terrified of the 13 of
people who said they reuse passwords all
of the time every single like these are
the people with one password the the
piece of text not the app uh it's it's
terrifying or I guess they only have one
account
it could be the answer
real single single sign on
I've only signed on once and I had one
password and that was it good
the problem with this uh these numbers
actually turns out uh that the same
survey asked who uses a password manager
and they said 24 of people said they use
a password manager now 35 of people said
they'd never reuse passwords so there's
an 11 of people in there that either
have incredible memories only one
account or they're lying
um and it could be any of them it's
probably not only one account uh it
could also be I guess a number of
Post-it notes around their monitors
um although I count that as a password
manager uh because if uh if your
physical security is such a problem that
people are reading your passwords off
the thing next to your monitor uh you
have a different problem a bigger
problem you have somebody in your house
um so 24 of people use a password
manager that's um that's quite good I
guess but we it could be better right
that's three quarters of people who are
leaving their own memory up to
remembering passwords
I'd always link a list of the top 10
passwords uh this was provided produced
by nordpass uh at the end of last year
um I always say one two three four five
six normally comes top but in 2022
apparently password has managed to top
it Well Done password
um
I do I really like how um you know that
in at number three are slightly less
lazy people where they can make it all
the way to the end of the keyboard for a
long and secure password
um
I was like guest and QWERTY just just
beautiful passwords all around
um so people are still doing this people
are still picking bad passwords all the
time so nordpass is a password manager I
don't know how they're Gathering their
users are just putting bad passwords
into their management I guess it's
terrifying
um
uh and then the problem is if if you
pick good passwords but they're reusing
them we have that issue in which other
websites and applications on the
internet are just handing the passwords
out to people uh if you are
um I hope you're aware of the site have
ibimponed.com if you're not uh it uh has
it it stores or it tracks all public
breaches of data allows you to enter
your email address or your phone number
and check how many times your data has
been leaked over the Internet
um which ones are like unencrypted
passwords and and
or just sort of data
um
I've been in so many breaches uh it's
it's very disappointing every single
time every single time you get another
email saying you're in another one
um this that breaching I I was a person
who used the same password all the time
at one point in my life I think we've
all been through it surely
um but I absolutely lost access to my
Spotify account and my Skype account one
time uh because it was leaked by it was
Adobe or LinkedIn or something like that
um it was that was sad it was a weird uh
experience as well I managed to get back
access to both of those accounts
eventually
um the Spotify one was fun because I
went through the the normal process with
filling in a form online and things like
that and they came back to me and said
we can't verify that you're the owner no
you can't so I dm'd them on Twitter and
I was back in within an hour
it's a different security issue there
um
and meanwhile once I managed to reset
access to the Skype account I logged in
to find out that somebody had been using
that account to proposition men in
French for marriage I think weirdly
um I actually I never actually stored
like a screenshot or any of the data
because I got so weirded out by it I
just went to try and delete it all and
just move on with my life
um especially because like they were
acting as if they're a woman and
speaking French but they still had my
username
super weird anyway I got back access to
them installed myself a password manager
and now talk about passwords so
it's life
and then this is my absolute favorite
thing it turns out you can just go and
ask people for their passwords and
they'll tell you
um uh coming up next is a clip a video
from Australian comedian couldn't see
Hussein who took a clipboard out onto
the streets and started asking people
questions weird or good questions and
some of them were what's your password
now some people respond correctly to
this but it gets terrifying after a
while
[Music]
and what's the password for your email
I shouldn't be giving you this you she's
actually crazy
what is your internet banking password
is it a number what's a number
and your PIN number
on the streets just a clipboard gives
people so much uh Authority that this
guy he's got a lanyard and a clip but
yeah exactly I particularly uh what I
like about this also is that for some
reason this got subtitled but only the
bit where he said the password and then
the subtitle is Stars
so people would just hand over their
password to you so it's bad passwords
are terrible and that is why we need to
get rid of them but
we have a long way to go with that we
have the technology but we also have
consideration uh for what we have in
place already
you see obviously Security in general is
a set of trade-offs and when we're
dealing with web applications uh things
we'd like people to use
um those trade-offs I think kind of end
up being between user experience and
security
we can't not have security because
people breaking into accounts and
propositioning men in French is is a bad
thing but without the user experience
especially if something like login which
is a which is a feature of so many
applications but never the feature
somebody is coming to your application
to use
um having that user experience to get
them through that process and do the
actual task they intended to do
um is is important in getting them
through that
safely and securely so if we consider
passwords on the kind of two axes of
user experience and security turns out
the experience is actually really bad
it's hard to remember good passwords
it's hard to choose good passwords you
sort of need a password manager this
third-party piece of software that
nobody actually tells you about when you
first start using the internet and so
it's bad it's a bad experience so how
about the security well we know that
we've just been through that it's also
bad
um we've spent our entire time building
these sites that have just a bad
experience it's easy to bring those easy
passwords like one two three four five
six
um when passwords are leaked as they are
being done all of the time
um users have been using those to take
credential stuffing attacks and and and
hack into other into your accounts where
you've reused that password and I
haven't even mentioned phishing yet but
of course they're vulnerable to that as
well
um so passwords it's bad what have you
been doing with our lives
obviously our first answer is to use a
password manager
um
but like I said that's a third party
thing it does help though like the
experience becomes better if you are a
password manager user you know that you
can auto fill your passwords in you
never have to know your password anymore
you get a unique one per site
it's a good experience
and it's more secure you end up getting
generated long and secure passwords and
unique ones
um there is still vulnerability to
phishing no one's stopping you copying
and pasting that password into an
account although
um certainly in the case of uh I use bit
Warden and and that certainly doesn't
offer up a password if it's on a
different domain to the one it was saved
on in the first place so it actually
does help a little bit more
of course the problem with password
managers is that not everybody uses them
and we can't make them all use them
um so we have to consider other ways
that we can encourage people to pick
long unique passwords that they don't
have to remember
can we improve this well we actually do
have for the technology to do this and I
think I've surprised many people in
talks like this that sometimes it's very
simple to do
easy first up uh HTML is right there
ready to help us out the autocomplete
attribute of the input element
is a magical little piece of technology
I absolutely love it
um I didn't realize I could feel this
way about an attribute but I do
uh if you put autocomplete's new
password on an input element like that
then browsers will suggest to you a new
secure long password this is Firefox uh
offering me a securely generated
password
um and of course that's going to
encourage people to store it in the
browser's password manager as well which
are getting better than nothing maybe
not the most secure places but better
than not uh using a password manager
uh and then the input element goes
further the autocomplete element goes
further to make it easier to it gives
hints to the browsers and to other
assistive technology uh for what what we
can get filled in here and autocomplete
user username if you put a type email
that's that's absolutely suggesting to
the browser that um that this is an
email that's a username that we can
autofill here that's nice
um we have different ones so we saw a
new password on the previous uh slide
this is current password for offering up
an existing password in place rather
than generating a new one and that works
really nicely particularly on those
pages where you want to change your
password and you have three inputs uh
one for the old one and two for the new
one so they match and using the correct
order complete on that is going to stop
people kind of either Auto completing
their old password into all three of the
form fields or um
uh yeah down
so uh HTML makes it easier and adding an
attribute oh my goodness that's easy
that's a nice way to to start things
rolling
but then there's the credential
management API and it's an API that's
actually been around for
seven eight years maybe uh it's it's
actually it's been around for a while
and it's not very popular because I
don't think people talk about it enough
and it's cool
it's cool because it allows us to in
this particular case uh control
um the data going in and outs out of the
browser's password manager
uh it allows us to store and retrieve
credentials in the browser
and this this will actually be useful
over the course of this uh this talk
we'll see more and more of the
credential management API but right now
um I'm just talking about password
credentials
and uh and so this is effectively all
the code you need uh to um store a
password credential in the browser uh we
checked to see if Pastor credential
exists and when it does and we have an
uh a credential that we understand that
we know this is either a registration or
like or a successful login or um a
change password form you can create a
password credential and then use the
Navigator credentials.store method to
ask to store in the browser now this is
going to pop uh permissions dialogue to
the user uh saying hey do you want to
store your password in the browser it
actually looks exactly the same as the
permissions dialog if you don't do this
but
the important thing is that if you have
asked for that permission in the first
place it means you can get those
credentials back out again and using
Navigator credentials.get and passing
the object with password true to it will
pop a permissions dialogue to the user
to say hey do you want to log in with
these uh credentials
uh if they respond yes then we get an
object back that has the username and
password it looks uh oh you can do it
silently as well in fact you don't have
to do the permissions dialog which is a
neat thing although it does make me a
little bit uncomfortable that people
just sort of automatedly logged back
into a site uh and so you can set that
up with unmediated as true and that
allows a seamless no interaction login
which is quite cool but you do have to
remember in that case that when somebody
signs out you don't want to be
automatically signing them back in again
and so you just call on prevent silent
access on the log out and they won't be
automatically logged back in they have
to choose to log in the next time
I say this looks a bit like this this is
after a um successful login or in in my
example if it's on the way through to
fact authentication as well but like at
the top there we get that save password
do you want to save it in your browser
um this is on an Android device so
actually it's offering to save it to
your Google account which means it's
also going to sync across devices you
can log in in one place and it will
offer it up in another place yes
so I I asked this when I first found out
about the oh sorry the question uh was
if you're using a third-party password
manager does that tie in with this at
all
um I asked this when the API came out
and I I think it was a evangelist from a
browser who I saw talking about it and
they said not yet uh and I don't think
that was seven years ago and I don't
think it does yet still but
um if you are using your password
manager
um you probably already have your
workflow with that right
um I know in in bit Warden which is that
I use
um it now autofills with uh command
shift L and I don't have to worry about
all of this it does the saving for me uh
this I'm trying to I think this is
useful for encouraging uh users who
aren't using those passive managers we
want to make them get more secure so
um if you if you're using password
manager you're probably safe already
[Music]
um
The Experience past this uh like I said
um this is going to sync across the
accounts so you could then go to your
desktop in this case and go and log in
and it would offer to log in and this um
horrible domain but that's just because
I was testing
um when you come back uh that's where
you call on Navigator credentials.get
and this is the permissions dialogue hey
do you want to sign in in as this
account uh and you just click sign in
it's a one tap one click sign in process
that's quite nice and it's more secure
you probably don't have to worry about
knowing that password anymore or typing
it in it's a one-click thing
so the experience becomes good it's a
nice experience and there's no need to
remember passwords not typing it in
because on the security side of things
we actually haven't necessarily made it
that much better the uh the fact that we
we've maybe added that autocomplete
attribute and it's offering to generate
a secure password it doesn't mean the
user has to choose to do so and they can
still put in password or one two three
four five six and so it's still
vulnerable basically to all the existing
things so better experience just as
vulnerable shame
still recommend it it's a better
experience
so what we do of course uh is we over
the years we've said passwords are bad
what do we do we need to add a second
step we need a second factor to make
things more secure
and we reach for two-factor
authentication the idea of having a
device or a something you know something
you own or potentially Biometrics as
well although I'm not such a fan of that
in terms of the two-factor
authentications because it's real hard
to rotate your fingerprints when they
get leaked
um two factors authentication you have
probably received text messages like
this uh with six city code saying hey
you can use this to log in
um
this this is good uh you know obviously
there are not obviously there is also
um authenticator apps as well
um I'm mostly going to concentrate on
the SMS part of this because it can be
better
um
because looking on the two factors here
we've actually regressed the experience
now that's the shame that's the sad
thing here we've now got to this
two-step login flow
um you tend to need another device or an
application on your device or to be able
to receive a text message if you happen
to be underground or in another country
and you're not connected to the network
uh you you can't log in at all and so
this this experience has kind of been
somewhat regressed but
the security side of things we can kind
of now overcome the password Problem by
making the second factor and the
combination of the two of them much
harder to break through
um doesn't stop them being vulnerable to
phishing though if you can fish a
username and password of somebody you
can fish a username password and six
digit code off of them and then plug
that straight into the other application
that you're trying to hack into
finally um in terms of SMS
there are targeted attacks on the SMS
Network that you can perform if you
happen to know somebody's phone number
and want to steal text messages from
them you can totally do that SMS is
remarkably broken
um uh it turns out this is known as it's
the ss7 problem ss7 is the system
question
uh
the problem is that you can be used to
track via
that is that is absolutely true
um
yes and and in the in I'm talking about
in course of trade-offs here
um is being tracked uh more or less a
Bad Thing compared to keeping the
account secure
it's a trade-off and and different
people have different answers to that so
we absolutely agree
um oh this is a good time to uh mention
uh talk about Twitter actually you know
earlier in the uh earlier in the year
where um Twitter decided to
uh turn off SMS two-factor
authentication for people not paying for
the service and a whole bunch of
um a whole bunch of people like
celebrated and when SMS is insecure
because of these potential targeted
attacks
um and the problem is uh they turned it
off for the
um people not paying for it people who
have large accounts uh and probably do
find it worthwhile to pay for Twitter
we're still allowed to use the less
secure version that's a bad start
um it also turned out that it's a
significant percentage of the people who
you have to that authentication turned
on in Twitter
um
use the SMS version
um so it actually just turned off a
whole security feature for them and sure
it was encouraging them to go to an
app-based thing but so many people I'm
sure
uh couldn't be bothered to change that
kind of thing and would just drop the
feature instead of using it
um and uh and the reasoning uh behind
dropping it was because
um uh Elon Musk was claiming that
Twitter were being scammed to the tune
of several uh tens of millions of
dollars uh by people
um just sending enormous numbers of
those two-factor authentication codes
now that is a problem but it's not the
user's fault it's not a user problem and
they're in fact ways to avoid
um SMS
I can't remember the word yeah like just
sending thousands and thousands of
messages if you were to for example rate
limit those things uh then you probably
find you're not spending 60 million
dollars a year on text messages that are
useless
uh also companies uh literally provide
this kind of thing are actually coming
up with the products and solutions to
fix that automatically for you as well
so
Twitter just removed security for people
and that makes me sad
um hopefully it does actually encourage
people to use an application but
removing two factories worse
can we meet different authentication
better though
uh it's not the greatest experience to
start with like I said that it regressed
the experience
um compared to just a password
and so I'm going to reach back to HTML
to start with it's always a good start
using the autocomplete attribute again
again my favorite attribute the
autocomplete attribute with one-time
code as a value will cause iOS and Mac
their Safari to offer to autocomplete an
incoming text message which is cool I
also like to point out that input mode
numeric is important here this is a text
field not a number field but you want
the number keyboard to show up when
people want to put things in just make
it easier I get a little video of this
nice this is that experience of logging
or getting a two-factor authentication
code sent on on Safari we go log in the
message comes through and there is the
code sitting at the top of the keyboard
I think that's quite nice it only took
17 characters to make that happen pretty
neat I reckon and then when you hit it
of course it auto fills and submits the
form it's nice and then
is that I actually uh if you have if
you're fully bought into the Mac
ecosystem you have your messages coming
through to your laptop and you use
Safari on the desktop
um then
it will auto complete on the desktop as
well I think that's that's quite
exciting too uh
we can log in
the code comes in and we get offered in
order to complete on the desktop of a
magical little experience actually that
uh that's kind of what apple good at the
times I think so that's Apple and iOS
but it only works in Safari which is a
shame
uh so
um instead uh Google and Chrome browser
decided they'd come up with a JavaScript
version of this instead
and we have the webrotp API the Weber
TPB API is actually just the credential
management API with a different name
it turns out it's all credential
management all the way down in this it's
it's wonderful
um you see last time we were working
with the password credential and this
time we can work with an OTP credential
you do have to make some changes though
to this works with text messages uh they
haven't got it to work with uh
authenticator apps yet so that's why I
don't spend too much time on them but uh
uh in the text message you do have to
change a couple of things uh in the
bottom line of the message you now have
to start with an at symbol the domain
you're logging into uh then a space a
hash and the number of the code uh
adding the domain there uh is a way to
kind of this is going to help us auto
complete things right and and that's
going to stop it auto completing onto
not to the site you're logging into so
it's it's a phishing protection which is
cool
and then like I said we then reach for
the OTP credential uh in um in Navigator
credentials uh in this case we're not we
don't need to store any credentials
we're just asking to get them from the
browser and so we ask Navigator
credentials get uh passing an object
saying OTP passing a transports property
and passing an array which can have one
element in it which is the string SMS
it's an interesting choice of an API
there I actually think
um it's good like that array can only
have that option in it right now and
like I said I'd like to see a feature in
which authenticator apps are integrated
into this kind of thing uh and and we
can say the transport is is app as well
as SMS and give it the options either
way
this is going to pop a permissions
dialogue to the user saying uh do you
want to allow the browser to copy from
your messages into this into this page
and when the user accepts that because
it seems like a lovely idea you get an
object with a with a co-property on it
that's the that's the thing and you can
pump that into your form field and move
on
and it looks a bit like this
um this is now on an Android device
uh we're gonna go log in
login
and then in comes the message we
actually see the text message coming at
the top and of course Google has done
work over the years with Android to like
make it easier to copy the number out of
there but this is even easier when we
get to this bit which says would you
like to allow Chrome to read the message
and into this number you click allow
and move straight on glorious
um
so if we consider this on our experience
versus security side of things our
two-factor authentication whilst we
added an extra step we've now managed to
reduce it to the most minimal kind of
version of that it's actually a lot more
um it's much nicer and if we add that
with the password credentials the
password credential side of things as
well our login can be two minimal
one-click steps which I think is very
cool we didn't take away from the fact
that you still need an app or or so you
still need a phone to receive a text
message and phone signal and the
potential privacy implications of that
um but the security is now great as well
we've got the two Factor authentication
uh leaked passwords are not going to be
a problem
um and only targeted SMS attacks which
are only really a problem for high value
accounts because they do take some
effort
um I was going to tell you how it works
uh yeah uh as a Telco
um right no anyone can be a Telco these
days it's amazing you just need the
right hardware and software in fact you
don't even need Hardware if you've got a
cloud you just need a server and it
turns out because
telcos and things were invented a long
time ago when it was hard to do that
trust was inherent in the system the
only people running telcos when it
started were governments and large
telcos who all knew each other and so
there's no authentication in that
Network so you can be a Telco and then
you can say hey
this phone is roaming on my network so
if you need to send a message to them
just pass over to me I'll get it to them
and there you go you just you can steal
people's SMS like that like it's not
trivial to do but it's not hard I want
to know that that's the same thing it's
not trivial to do but it is possible
that's why it requires a targeted attack
and you need to know the person's phone
number
c-fact authentication is not just a
solely SMS we have security Keys as well
you probably have a you know a UBC or
something like that which you use
particularly with work with business
things to uh look after your security
there
um and this is
powered in the browser by web
authentication the web authentication
API which of course is the credential
management API
just keep giving it new names
web authentication web will then allows
the browser to generate a public and
private key pair which you can then use
share the public key and keep the
private key on on the device
and that allows you to sign things
um in this case this is creating the
public key a property private key we
asked navigate to credentials to create
a public key the server sends a
challenge a set of random bytes and we
put some other details into this as well
um such as sort of the RP this is the
relaying party that's just the domain
it's on the the keys will be tied to the
domain so it's uh it's impossible to use
this key on a different a different
domain so anti-fishing uh that's not a
problem we obviously we have some user
details as well and then at the bottom
the uh the algorithms there just the two
widely available
um
algorithms for the encryption
and so we asked to create this that's
going to pop up permissions dialogue to
the user to say hey do you want to
create a public key
um for this site uh and uh and when they
say yes it will
um
create the popular private key and
return the public key and sign uh the
challenge with that private key send the
server send the challenge the sign
Challenge and the public key back to the
server and the server will be able to
use the public key to decrypt The
Challenge and verify that it was the
original Challenge and thus connect that
public key to your account in your
browser
then on the other side uh when you come
back to log in again and do uh do the
challenge
um the second time we just call it
navigate to credentials get with the
public key we get another challenge from
the server in this case we're not
creating it we're just using the
existing private key to sign this
Challenge and return the sign challenge
to the server at which point the server
uses the public key that it has stored
to verify that signature verify the
challenge and log you in brilliant uh
this uh I was gonna say this also uh
this works over multiple different ways
that uh authenticator keys can work
whether it's USB Bluetooth low energy or
NFC like all of those are available for
our via this method and this is quite
cool like uh using a security key like
that it's actually a very minimal step
right it tends to include a uh an
interaction with it just touching it
um and so the steps are indeed minimal
we've still got two factors uh two
factors two steps but again minimal
steps
of course need an authenticator key
though which most users most people in
the world don't have uh they cost money
and people don't tend to want to uh pay
for money you can use your phone that's
true I've never managed to do it though
but like you know people also don't
install authenticator apps and uh for do
that authentication either people don't
do stuff we have to help them along the
way otherwise they've all used a
password manager and we'd be fine we
wouldn't even have this discussion
um
and then the other thing is that the uh
the private key uh sticks with the
device so you have to if you're using
multiple devices move your key around or
be able to register multiple
um security keys but on the other hand
this is public private key cryptography
uh we've got a second Factor helping us
out and it's unlinkable it's just a
public key all you can do is verify
challenges that were signed with the
private key
um
give your public key away to everyone it
doesn't matter
public as you can't leak it and it's
fishing resistant as well as we saw you
have to tie it to the domain that you're
on so it can't be used to log in to some
other domain uh you can't give up your
private key it's stuck on the device and
you can't get at it it's cool
um but that issue I think mostly is that
uh the fact that that's most users in
the world don't or won't have this so
this eventually brings us to getting rid
of passwords like I think we do need to
improve the experience as we go improve
the security as we go for the existing
things we have but now we can get rid of
passwords as well
I do get to uh take a little two or
three magic links here uh medical links
being the idea where you put an email
into into the into the sign up process
and the site will send you a link to
your email address with a unique
generated code that will log you into
the website
um
oops
but they're all right magic links I
guess
there's no need for a password anymore
that's lovely but it does rely on email
sending emails is a pain receiving
emails is a pain uh emails not going to
spam is a pain
but my biggest problem with it really is
just friction
um I was already annoyed to be having to
be sent to my phone to pick up a text
message with a six digit code in it if I
have to open my email I'm immediately
distracted by all the other emails
they've been waiting for me uh and uh
and and it's just friction I don't like
it but it's pretty secure like it's just
sending that unique uh link over yes
oh you want things reading your emails I
mean maybe perhaps
I think we can do better I think we can
do better
um excuse me sorry
it's pretty secure but um yeah I just
don't like it I also have one
application I have to log into uh for
work in which I have it has an email a
password and then sends me a magic link
which is very annoying like if I'm if
you're gonna send me a magic link don't
make me write a password in as well
that's pointless
answer that's the password full uh kind
of experience at that point
so magic links I I you know they're all
right and I don't think they're the real
answer the real answer to our uh to our
to our problems here the solution for
everything is the world of pass keys
Pass key is of course just the
credential management API
um
actually the Multi-Device credentials
they're actually just the web
authentication API uh so a subset of our
credential management API but they are
Multi-Device credentials this won't make
this is what makes them sort of more
usable
hey you see what they are is web
authentication but they use the platform
authenticator so in the case of my
laptop here it's the fingerprint in the
case of my phone it's my face ID
um it relies on the platform
authenticator which is good because
users are starting to have devices that
have platform authenticators on them
and what it does is it allows you to
verify the user on the device because it
uses that platform authenticator that is
secured by biometric the user is
verified on the device but those
Biometrics are never shared with a third
party with the server with your
application they stay on the device
um so you get to verify the user there
and then because it's using the same
thing as web authentication uh it's it's
signing a challenge that authenticates
the user with server
um like it's it's effectively the same
um
flow of of setting up a public private
key and then verifying
by signing a challenge
and so then you're authenticated and so
these are now called These are
Multi-Device credentials because they
sync across your devices
um
so that's why it relies both on the
platform authenticator and the fact that
the platform is in control as well
and then there is a mechanism for using
it across devices where the sync is not
possible and so because this is tied to
the security platform itself
um
your past keys can share across Apple
devices if you're in the Apple ecosystem
using uh
keychain on iCloud
if you're on Google devices if you're on
Chrome OS or Android you can sync across
those things but if you're trying to use
a chrome on a desktop or another browser
on the desktop you can't sync there
um
but there is this other cross-device
mechanism
question
yes
no absolutely sorry yeah the private key
being used to say the challenge is not
baked into the hardware it is generated
on a site-by-site basis based on the
rolling party
privately
provides me that authentication that's
good yes
it's not the hardware token now it's it
is your device uh and inside the
hardware authenticator that is you know
the fingerprint or the or whatever the
secure Enclave is on these devices it is
the case that we now have to trust
um uh our platforms Google or Apple
pretty much the only two doing it right
now in order to do that but uh yeah um
I'm not there is actually there is I
will dig this out there is a uh good
article from the Chrome team actually
might be the Android team because it's
the same thing it's available in Android
and iOS as well uh that actually does
explain this and that's what I should
have uh boned up on before you asking
difficult questions like that
um I will share that out with Links at
the end
um this is just a snippet of uh I love
this because uh Java JavaScript is
becoming Java
um when we want to use uh pass Keys like
this we have to check a few things
because it's web authentication but with
some extra bits and so you have to ask
two things uh whether there is a user
verifying platform authenticator
available uh meaning you know does it
have a fingerprint or a face ID or
something like that and then is
conditional mediation available and that
is actually asking whether the browser
is capable of offering up the available
keys that you could use uh to you as
part of the interface
once you have those and you can ask for
them you then do web authentication much
the same as before but with a couple
little added things in this case just at
the bottom there you have to add the
thing saying we need authenticator
selection the authenticator attachment
must be platform that ties it to the
fact that it is your device platform
authentic platform identifier and then
require resident key means you are
saving the key on the device which
allows it to go through the syncing
process as well have a question go for
it
okay you
are not UV keys they are different hello
hello
has to be the platform authenticator the
platform
thank you
and not a UB key uh past keys are not
single key devices uh they have the the
intention is for the sinking
uh and so yeah if you want to implement
this as a website and still allow people
to use Uber keys to to log in
um then you would you would do two
things but like you
yeah
yeah oh and this is what it looks like
uh this actually is a is the full demo
of how a thing works using a demo on a
site called passkeys.io
when you go to login this one offers you
to set up a new account with a pass key
and this is me in Safari on the desktop
so that's the permissions for the thing
it's doing the platform authenticator
makes the private key sends it back to
the password to the server and you're
logged in nice and then you can sign out
sign back in it's going to ask again I
did this demo a few times so it had a
bunch of options but it's the sonar
Source address there that we're looking
for and we're we're fingerprinted and
signed in again now we go to the phone
uh this was a live done recording and
the pass key is now synced across to the
account already uh so we can just hit
sign in with the pass key it gives me
all those options again we're looking
for my Sonar Source email address which
is at the bottom face ID sign in and we
can see we're logged in
and it's the same Pass Key across both
sides
and then finally if I wanted to go to
another browser Chrome for example this
does not have syncing available so we
can still have to sign in with a pass
key and what it's going to do is say I
know that we don't have a plus key saved
and give us this QR code instead we can
then scan the QR code with a mobile
device
and that's going to offer to sign in
with a pass key and it's going to give
the same list of pass keys that that
application has the one at the bottom
Source we Face ID
it shares the pass key back to the uh
back to the browser and allows you to
sign in that's not stored in that
browser if I was to sign in again with
that browser
um I would have to go through that
process again
uh and um but that's quite nice the fact
that we have that available uh to uh to
to do so
works
now what you would need to do for this
you would probably still need to build
multiple keys so that when you do find
somebody logged in
um you can offer to save a new Pass key
for their new device I have a question
what's the account recovery process
absolutely well so since it's synced to
your platform account
um
these keys are always available to
retrieve from that either Apple keychain
or um or Google account so actually it
does make
that recovery sort of both easier and uh
no longer in your own hands um so it's
sort of a benefit in both ways there
you you yeah you just you still need an
account recovery but in this case
um it sort of relies on an account that
is probably more important to you uh
like your Apple or your Google account
is something you would look after uh
whereas every other website in the world
uh is less important to you probably
I lost device well
because it syncs across things as long
as you can always log back into your
device with that account you can always
access it again
really
come back to your second
that's all right
um so we now have no need for a password
um we do require a platform
authenticator so not all devices will
have this so maybe we can't entirely
drop passwords and the other methods of
logging in uh but
um platform authenticators are more and
more popular and this thinking Behavior
Uh makes it a bit more magical
experience for for users as it works
across devices it's also then phishing
resistant we're still doing public
private key cryptography here uh it
seems it basically does sort of both
factors of a two-factor step in one go
with our ability to verify the user on
the device and then authenticate using
the key uh or by signing the challenge
and it's unleakable again with public
keys in the in the domain so it doesn't
matter
now question
of Biometrics yes
yes
don't know we'll share we'll we'll dig
that blog post out again
um
I I I'm not fully a security
professional I'm a I'm a fan of of of
web authentic of authentication and
making it better and things like that uh
which is why I'm not the uh I'm not the
certainly not a cryptographer and it's
also why I get to put this on the screen
is it perfect maybe
it's certainly better uh past keys are
certainly a better experience and better
security uh than everything we have
existing and it doesn't take an awful
lot to implement
other other drawbacks of course there
are it's browsers there's browser
support to be dealt with but uh this is
actually supported in most major
browsers now
um those uh the video demo there showed
uh Chrome and Safari so it works in all
chromium things uh it isn't Firefox is
the one that we're missing out on
but uh it looks like uh Firefox should
support it by the end of this year uh
but I'm not capable of promising
features being shipped by a browser
um but I think Firefox is basically the
last one to come on board uh they
they're obviously enthusiastic about it
uh but it's just not done yet
uh it's coming
uh one password uh have uh I'm probably
gonna have to change their name uh
because they are on board with this they
realize they know the passwords are bad
and they have an entire business based
on it and they're trying to implement it
as well
um
and and Implement their own version of a
encrypted uh Pass key store uh so that
the one password extension will be able
to handle this for you as well
um and that will then work across
browsing devices uh there so behind it
as well that they're also trying to
encourage more people to implement this
and so that passkeys.directory uh one
password and maintaining a list of uh
places that now support passkeys for
login I've already updated my Microsoft
account you can do that to log in bypass
Keys only which is very cool and you can
add them to GitHub but only as like a
second Factor not a full login
experience
uh there's other things I think um eBay
and PayPal in the US right now they're
rolling it out uh support pass keys this
thing but but go go check all the other
people implementing this on past
keys.directory it's very cool
um so ultimately one of the
recommendations what are the takeaways
here uh
first up I think we you know we should
start building this in I want to see
more of this and and so I recommend we
build longer experiences where we detect
fast key support and offer it up first
make it the default uh and uh there is
probably going to be a bit of a learning
curve for users as they would expect
their expectations are going to be
changed but the more we do that the more
we can get over it and and offering it
first is going to encourage that greater
security
it's important to support multiple pass
Keys uh like I said you don't want to
necessarily have to always go through
that QR code route to log in if you are
doing across different browsers so
offering up to save a new Pass key for a
new browser is a good idea
then we fall back to passwords with
two-fact authentication don't
don't leave a single Factor as a way to
get in uh to an account you're only as
strong as sort of the weakest security
that you have
um
so fall back to passwords with two facts
for the negation and then once users can
use their password pass Keys you can
offer to upgrade them and remove old and
weak credentials like I have uh deleted
my password for signing into my
Microsoft account because I have the
pass key set up and I'm confident in
that
like I said I do have some links on all
of this I will share them out in the
slack room actually that's probably a
good place and probably on Twitter as
well
uh
um
that doesn't include currently the um
that that blog post that I'm going to
share about how the secure uh syncing is
done but I will add that as well
and that's it uh let's get rid of
passwords and thanks very much my name
is Phil Nash I'm a developer Advocate at
Sona it's been absolute pleasure
chatting with you today thank you
thank you
[Music]